a few years ago i broke into my own
house uh i had just driven home it was
around midnight in the dead of montreal
winter i'd been visiting my friend jeff
across town
and
the thermometer on the front porch read
minus 40 degrees
and don't bother asking if that celsius
or fahrenheit minus 40 is where the two
scales meet
it was very cold and as i stood on the
front porch fumbling in my pockets
i found i didn't have my keys
in fact i could see them through the
window lying on the dining room table
where i'd left them
so i quickly ran around and tried all
the other doors and windows and they
were locked tight
i thought about calling a locksmith at
least i had my cell phone but at
midnight it could take a while for a
locksmith to show up and it was cold
i couldn't go back to my friend jeff's
house for the night because i had an
early flight to europe the next morning
and i needed to get my passport in my
suitcase
so desperate and freezing cold i found a
large rock and i broke through the
basement window cleared out the shards
of glass i crawled through i found a
piece of cardboard and taped it up over
the whole opening figuring that in the
morning on the way to the airport i
could call my contractor and ask him to
to fix it this was going to be expensive
but probably no more expensive than the
middle of the night locksmith so i
figured under the circumstances i was
coming out even
now i'm a neuroscientist by training and
i know a little bit about how the brain
performs under stress
it releases cortisol that raises your
heart rate
it modulates adrenaline levels and it
clouds your thinking
so the next morning
when i woke up i'm too little sleep
worrying about the hole in the window
and the mental note that i had to call
my contractor and the freezing
temperatures and the meetings i had
upcoming in europe and
you know with all the cortisol in my
brain my thinking was cloudy but i
didn't know it was cloudy because my
thinking was cloudy and
it wasn't until i got to the airport
check encounter
that i realized i didn't have my
passport
so i raced home in the snow and ice 40
minutes got my passport raced back to
the airport i made it just in time but
they had given away my seat to someone
else so i got stuck in the back of the
plane next to the bathrooms in a seat
that wouldn't recline on an eight-hour
flight
well i had a lot of time to think during
those eight hours of no sleep
and i started wondering are there things
that i can do systems that i can put
into place
that'll prevent bad things from
happening
or at least if bad things happen will
minimize the likelihood of it being a
total catastrophe
so i started thinking about that but my
thoughts didn't crystallize until about
a month later i was having dinner with
my colleague danny kahneman the nobel
prize winner and i somewhat
embarrassedly told him about having
broken my window and
you know forgot my passport and danny
shared with me that he'd been practicing
something called
prospective hindsight
it's something that he had gotten from
the psychologist gary klein who had
written about it a few years before also
called the pre-mortem now you all know
what the post-mortem is whenever there's
a disaster you know team of experts come
in and they try to figure out what went
wrong right well in the pre-mortem danny
explained you look ahead and you try to
figure out all the things that could go
wrong
and then you
try to figure out what you can do to
prevent those things from happening or
to minimize the damage so what i want to
talk to you about today are some of the
things we can do in the form of a
pre-mortem some of them are obvious
some of them are not so obvious i'll
start with the obvious ones around the
home
designate a place for things that are
easily lost
now this sounds like common sense and it
is but there's a lot of science to back
this up based on the way our spatial
memory works there's a structure in the
brain called the hippocampus that
evolved over tens of thousands of years
to keep track of the locations of
important things
uh where the well is where fish can be
found that stand of fruit trees
where the friendly and enemy tribes live
the hippocampus is the part of the brain
that in london taxi cab drivers becomes
enlarged it's the part of the brain that
allows squirrels to find their nuts and
if you're wondering somebody actually
did the experiment while they cut off
the olfactory scents of the squirrels
and they could still find their nuts
they weren't using smell they were using
the hippocampus this exquisitely evolved
mechanism in the brain for finding
things
but it's really good for things that
don't move around much not so good for
things that move around so this is why
we lose car keys and reading glasses and
passports so in the home designate a
spot for your keys a hook by the door
maybe a decorative bowl for your
passport a particular drawer for your
reading glasses a particular table if
you designate a spot and you're
scrupulous about it your things will
always be there when you look for them
what about travel take a cell phone
picture of your credit cards your
driver's license your passport
mail it to yourself so it's in the cloud
if these things are lost or stolen you
can facilitate replacement
now these are some rather obvious things
remember when you're under stress the
brain releases cortisol cortisol is
toxic and it causes cloudy thinking so
part of the practice of the premortem is
to recognize that under stress you're
not going to be at your best and you
should put systems in place
and there's perhaps no more stressful a
situation than when you're confronted
with a medical decision to make and at
some point all of us are going to be in
that position where we have to make a
very important decision about the future
of our medical care or that of a loved
one to help them with the decision and
so i want to talk about that and i'm
going to talk about a very particular
medical condition
but this stands as a proxy for all kinds
of medical decision making and indeed
for financial decision making and social
decision making any kind of decision you
have to make that would benefit from a
rational assessment of the facts
so suppose you go to your doctor and the
doctor says i just got your lab work
back
your cholesterol is a little high
now you all know that cholesterol is
high cholesterol is associated with an
increased risk of cardiovascular disease
heart attack stroke and so you're
thinking having high cholesterol isn't
the best thing and so the doctor says
you know i'd like to give you a drug
that'll help you lower your cholesterol
a statin
and you've probably heard of statins you
know that they're among the most widely
prescribed drugs in the world today you
probably even know people who take them
and so you're thinking yeah give me the
statin
but there's a question you should ask at
this point a statistic you should ask
for that most doctors don't like talking
about and pharmaceutical companies like
talking about even less
uh it's for the number needed to treat
now what is this the nnt
it's the number of people that need to
take a drug or undergo a surgery or any
medical procedure before one person is
helped
you're thinking what kind of crazy
statistic is that right the number
should be one my doctor wouldn't
prescribe something to me if it's not
going to help
but actually medical practice doesn't
work that way and it's not the doctor's
fault if if anybody's fault it's the
fault of scientists like me we haven't
figured out the underlying mechanisms
well enough but galaxo smith klein
estimates that ninety percent of the
drugs work in only thirty to fifty
percent of the people
so the number needed to treat for the
most widely prescribed statin
what do you suppose it is
how many people have to take it before
one person's helped 300.
this is according to research by
research practitioners jerome groupen
and pamela hartsband independently
confirmed by bloomberg.com i ran through
the numbers myself
300 people have to take the drug for a
year before one heart attack stroke or
other adverse event is prevented now
you're probably thinking well okay uh
one in 300 chance of lowering my
cholesterol why not doc give me the
prescription anyway but you should ask
at this point for another statistic and
that is tell me about the side effects
right so for this particular drug the
side effects occur in five percent of
the patients and they include terrible
things debilitating muscle and joint
pain
gastrointestinal distress but now you're
thinking well five percent not very
likely it's going to happen to me i'll
still take the drug but wait a minute
remember under stress we're not thinking
clearly so think about how you're going
to work through this ahead of time so
you don't have to manufacture the chain
of reasoning on the spot 300 people take
the drug right one person's helped five
percent of those 300 have side effects
that's 15 people
you're 15 times more likely to be harmed
by the drug
than you are to be helped by the drug
now i'm not saying whether you should
take the statin or not i'm just saying
you should have this conversation with
your doctor medical ethics requires it
it's part of the principle of informed
consent you have the right to have
access to this kind of information to
begin the conversation about whether you
want to take the risks or not now you
might be thinking i've pulled this
number out of the air for shock value
but in fact it's rather typical this
number needed to treat for the most
widely performed surgery on men over the
age of 50 removal of the prostate for
cancer the number needed to treat is 49
that's right 49 surgeries are done for
every one person who's helped and the
side effects in that case
occur in 50 percent of the patients they
include impotence erectile dysfunction
urinary incontinence rectal tearing
fecal incontinence and if you're lucky
and you're one of the 50 percent who has
these they'll only last for a year or
two
so
the idea of the pre-mortem is to think
ahead of time to the questions that you
might be able to ask that will push the
conversation forward you don't want to
have to manufacture all of this on the
spot and you also want to think about
things like quality of life because you
have a choice oftentimes do i want a
shorter life that's
or a longer life that might have a great
deal of pain towards the end these are
things to talk about and think about now
with your family and your loved ones you
might change your mind in the heat of
the moment but at least you're practiced
with this kind of thinking
remember our brain uh under stress
releases cortisol and one of the things
that happens at that moment is a whole
bunch of systems shut down there's an
evolutionary reason for this face to
face with a predator you don't need your
digestive system or your libido or your
immune system because if your body is
expending metabolism on those things and
you don't react quickly you might become
the lion's lunch and then none of those
things matter
what uh unfortunately one of the things
that goes out the window during those
time to stress is rational logical
thinking as danny kahneman and his
colleagues have shown
so we need to train ourselves to think
ahead to these kinds of situations
i think the important point here
is recognizing that all of us are flawed
we all are going to fail now and then
the idea is to think ahead to what those
failures might be to put systems in
place that will help minimize the damage
or to prevent the bad things from
happening in the first place
getting back to that snowy night in
montreal when i got back from my trip i
had my contractor install a combination
lock next to the door
with a key to the front door in it an
easy to remember combination and i have
to admit i still have piles of mail that
haven't
been sorted and piles of emails that i
haven't gone through so i'm not
completely organized but i see
organization as a gradual process and
i'm getting there thank you very much
[Music]